so I already created our account
settings and created a campaign for
customer acquisition promo offer and I
started with our first ad group dog
owners because one of our main goals was
to increase traffic of dog owners 5%
monthly for the next four months you can
see here in my AdWords account we have
dog owners which is under the customer
acquisition promo offer campaign so this
is our first ad group then I want to
create an ad and we need to enter in the
headline let's talk about this for a
headline we're only have 25 characters
to promote our product and service so we
really want to grab people's attention
and a good option here is to include the
keywords you've chosen we're going to
use luxury dog sitting next we have our
display URL we're going to use a bark
netcom for the display URL this is the
web address that will appear on your ad
this URL must match the domain people
will land on when they click on your ad
so if you want them to land on a
specific page of your website you can
still just use your home page like we
did with a bark mint com as long as it's
the same domain name okay let's go back
to AdWords next we're going to need to
do our description line 1 and
description line two so let's talk about
these description line one will be below
the display URL or it'll be displayed as
part of the headline you have 35
characters to use when attracting your
customers think about adding a call to
action here and don't forget sometimes
the description line one and other parts
of your ad can be seen along with your
headline if AdWords thinks it's going to
help you perform better so don't just
write this off we're going to use get
fifteen percent off your first booking
as our first description line if for
description line to the location of your
ad dictates where description line two
will be seen let's look at the example
they show us so we're going to use your
dog deserves the best day now we can see
what the ad would look like if it's a
top or bottom add or if it's a side view
add now I don't really like this top or
bottom view add without any punctuation
so I need to add that I period here and
maybe get a little bit more excited
about our fifteen percent off offer okay
so that changes the layout of our ad you
can see the top and bottom add the
description line one is now equal to the
headline and description line two is at
the bottom all by itself now for a side
the description line 1 is the first line
in description line two is the second
line so you can play around with this to
make sure you're happy with the way it
looks and feels and you can check out
the sample ads that Google Offers to get
some inspiration now the fun part of
this is you really don't have to kill
yourself over finding the best creative
a door wording for each ad yeah you want
to put some thought into it but each ad
group is going to have a few different
ads with a few different versions of
wording so you can launch your campaign
and start tracking the performance of
the different ads this way you'll be
able to see which messaging drove the
most clicks and have the most conversion
rates on your site and you can always
just delete the least successful one so
we still need to fill in our final URL
our final URL is the website people will
reach when they click on your ad so this
is your landing page you're going to
want to use a URL that best matches the
ad that you're promoting so for us we're
going to use a specific landing page for
our fifteen percent off promo which is a
bark Montcalm backslash welcome promo we
can also see what our app will look like
on different mobile devices depending on
the settings you chose for your ad group
if you have a mobile website you can add
in your URL for mobile it'll just take
them to the mobile version of your
landing page